那我们进入我们今天的第二个环节
我们会去跟余昊老师探讨一下
就是比如说作为前端的专家是要怎么样去成长的
ok 那我们现在先来谈一谈第一个问题吧
就是比如说从整个故事来开始
就是余昊老师你选择做前端那个初中是什么样子
对 其实这个也是
我觉得大家可能做前端都是有这个
一些因素吧 我觉得
那我做前端 其實這個時間也比較久
就是我可能現在從我剛接觸技術開始說
就是那我可能是初中的時候 因為是初一 初二的時候
其實接觸到了這個可以理解的是計算機技術
真正算是技術上的東西
那我剛開始其實先從這個VB開始做的
因為那個時候實際上你都有一個小白
會說一個初中生其實你不太清楚說
我應該做什麼東西
那我的机缘小伙伴说是我舅舅给我买了一本书
是这个叫VB 程序开发
就类似这样一个名字嘛
然后那我OK 那就看一看嘛
然后看看就是还挺有意思的
OK 那我就可能自己写一些
然后就发现说啊原来计算机不只可以打游戏
还可以去写一些代码
然后自己来做到一些这个其他的一些奇怪物的事情啊
然后呢我就慢慢的开始这个从VB开始就开始
是接觸相关的一些技术
然后我其实技术的前端应该是从VB
然后到VBS
因为VBS那个时候还是就是乱七能够去跑
所以他的当初那个定位是跟这个Jazz是最等的
然后呢VBS之后呢
其实你就发现玩这个东西的很多
那个时候也是比较年轻嘛
可能说想写一些这种
因为那个时候有一类这种
我们说恶意的这种脚本程序
就是用VBS来写的
那你可能就比较好奇
比如说我用vbs什么的写一些可以整人的一些小东西
比如说我可以写一些这种按照这个我去查时间
比如说每每个小时在某个时间点
我就把别人的工区可以直接弹出来
这种小脚本恶意小脚本
然后通过这种方式我就看了很多vbs相关的一些内容
然后再后来呢就是发现vbs好像好像网络上用的人也不多
我除了像我說這些這種小惡意程序惡意腳本來說
其他的可能沒有他用途
因為那個時候逐漸其實大家也是像JS來靠攏
然後隨後呢我可能就轉到了JS這邊
然後那個時候其實也是
也是趕上這個時代的一個一個一個一個產物
就是那個時候很多人會寫一些自己的空間嘛什麼的
那我覺得每個人可能都有自己的空間
那幸虧那個時候我有點這種JS技術
我可能說OK那我要不自己打一個網站
打一個blog這種網站
然后写一些可能跟别人这种网站或者说空间blog不太一样的东西
然后那个时候呢从那个时候开始其实我是算开始接触到外部开发相关的内容吧
呃然后一直到可能就要到高中的话也是差不多以前在搞这一块内容
我自己就是弄自己的网站嘛搞个博客呀发发这文章啊
但是那个文章就比较水呀也不是也不能算是技术文章
可能就是別人洗完之後
我朝過來 提到自己的博客裡面
就覺得是我超過來就是我的東西了
然後後面可能就是大學的
大學的話 其實我沒有在外部這邊花很多時間
大學的話 我印象裡就是
記得的唯一的這個參加的
或者說跟技術相關的
就是其實我做了一部分安卓相關的內容
因為那個時候也是比賽嘛
就是讓你用這個手機app
就是比如說安卓上的app
然後來完成一個任務
然後你需要跟其他同學比賽來說
誰用的時間最短
所以從那開始
其實我做了一部分安卓的開發
所以這個也導致我說
我大學畢業的時候
其實第一份面的工作
其實是做安卓開發的
是一個遊戲公司
然後那個地方其實
很有印象
当时就是实习
应该算实习还是
应该算实习
实习到第三天
我觉得可能这公司的环境不再适合
我就抖
然后后边我再找到下一家真正
工作了一两年的第一家公司的时候
其实就是做这个外部相关的内容了
但那个时候还不说完全做一个前段过程师
我的一家公司其实是做这个
用PHP来做一些网站的一些内容的
在PHP你也知道其实是一种
Service at Render
其实那我来做的话
其实它不是一个很正式的一个前后灯分离
对上一个架构
所以那个时候也说
一边写一些PGP的接口
然后一边可能另一方面搞一搞
这个跟Web相关内容
比如H5啊
比如说这个网页
CFS相关的内容
然后从那之后
可能我就是主要是
Focus在前段这一块
包括我的这个上一代公司
和现在这公司
也是主要是做
前端这一块的内容,对,所以说也没有,不前端也没有一个说什么初中吧,就是你不是说,也不是说他就怎么样怎么样,我觉得就是无非是说你整个的这个,从小到大整个的这个发展方向,那只是只是说在某一个先典你可能选择了做这个事情,但是这个选择为什么选择他做他呢,可能也跟我之前的一些经济有关,因为我之前可能很小的时候做过前端,OK,我知道他什么东西,那这个前端也没有一个初中吧,也不是说他就怎么样怎么样,我觉得就是无非是说你整个的这个从小到大整个的这个发展的方向,那只是只是说在某一个先典你可能选择了做这个事情,但是这个选择为什么选择他做他呢,可能
这个领域,它内容有什么,那我可能就做它了,所以也没有一个比较明确的一个出动,对,可以,是的,所以我觉得其实在整个过程中,慢慢的就是可能确定了这样的一个方向吗?对,是的,是的,但也有可能,也有人可能会说,就是,就是因为,我觉得有可能有可能是从其他行业转行的嘛,那他们可能会在做这个计算机技术这个,这个,或者叫这个行业的时候,可能会有一个名字,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,对,
面臨一個決策,比如說我到底要做前端還是後端還是做什麼
那其實前端相比於其他,我覺得
這個大家可能都知道,就一個比較好的優勢就是說
它其實是一個很快就讓你所見即所得的這樣一個技術
就是你不用花太多的成本就能夠享受你去做一個東西的一個成就感
那不像我做後端或者做更深一點,比如說操作系統
那这东西可能需要很多年的积累才能够有一些进步
但是前段不是
比如说我自己搭个博客
那我觉得就成就感就能够铺使你去继续去谈出更多内容
所以我觉得这是前段相对于其他领域的一个好的地方
明白
对
可以
OK
然后那应该也讲到就是其实在整个过程中其实也是从初中开始
可能就开始接触
然后又到现在整个进入的paper
其实我想知道就是在从一个作为新手开发者
然后到现在的话就是你今天的那些成长阶段
然后这阶段的话对你来说
你觉得有了相当比较重要的一些一些内容是什么
我上一阶段其实刚才也大致旅游一下
就是其实从初中然后到大学做软卓
然后到披萨公司的PGP
然后后边可能就是做前端
然后再进一步可能是自己的兴趣
比如说外国商贼或其他类型内容
我觉得契机的话可以总结几个点,第一点就是说我接触到这个计算机技术的一个时间点,就是我出中的时候,其实那本书,就VB程序设计入门这本书,它其实是开启了我做计算机技术这样一个时间节点,一个契机或者说是一个,
然后另外的几个节点可能就是我大学的时候做这个竞赛
然后做这个安卓开发
因为那个时候也是在想说我毕业到底是要做哪一方面的内容吗
然后第三个契机可能就是说我这个因为做竞赛其实导致我其实
美感很秋招然后导致我其实做第一大公司其实做PGP
然后让我接触PGP长一个东西
然后最后呢,其实随着我的这个职场,可能工作时间越来越久,那我从PGP主任就确认了,OK,那我可能说我要做前端这块,然后再往后,你可以,你可以理解别说,我这个15,18点的时候,可能接受的话三分三个技术,那我其实我在这本技术上其实也花了很多时间,我觉得这么来看的话,就是这样几个实验级点是对我来说比较重要的,对,OK,所以其实我觉得比较关键的一个点,就对你来说,就是对你来说,对你来说,对你来说,对你来说,对你来说,对你来说,对你来说,对你来说,对你来说,对你来说,对你来说,对你来说,对你来说,对你来说
就是你在这个关键的节点上所做的选择
决定了你到现在的一个状态的一个很重要的因素
对不对
对 是的 是的
其实这个就是一个不断选择的过程
就是你也可能说我哪个选择是对哪个选择是错
其实每个人在不同阶段都有不同的选择
我拿到了一个什么
对
明白
所以我是觉得
当你在做选择的时候
我觉得可能更多的还是遵循了自己的内心
对吧
其实可能就是很真正的
说实话可能也不是
其实我们说理想一点
ideo类就是说我每个阶段
我每个选择都已经很慎重的去决定
但实际上有很多去选择
可能就不是
比如说我接下公司去做安卓
但是我因为我待了两三天
我发现这个环境可能不是很自由
就是可能比较压抑吧
工作起来
那我就想,那我就做这个,我就可能去换了一家公司,去写BGP了
其实这个东西也是你意料不到的吧,我觉得也是
OK,好的,谢谢宇航老师
OK,另外有个事情我觉得就是对于,估计这个事情可能对于宇航老师来说本身也很重要
就是因为你写了一本深入浅出Webel Zemmen里的书嘛
然后我想了解一下就这本书对于你来说本身的意义在于什么样子
对 这本书其实我觉得这个意义从意义来讲来看
其实它就是国内第一本这个介绍外论书
其实当时我本身已经没有打算写书了
就是我当时在看这个Webdumlet这么技术的时候是写了几篇不课
然后后面就有这个编辑找到我说
那你想不想把你的这个内容组成一本书呢
因为国内也没有类似的书嘛
所以我就想 OK 那既然我做了
那我就把这个东西
把它往上的更好可能做到底吧
这样子 正好也是给股
把这个技术已经国内很多人可能知道一下说
OK 国外有哪些新的技术
那然后在这个开发
那它可能会有哪些潜能
可能对我们的整个的web这个产业
可能会有什么样的一个改变
所以我就想以这种方式来把这本书给写起来
但实际上真正写起来的一个发现
其实我们先说写书本身就时间很长对吧
我当时这个书可能有500多页
我写了可能有七八个月或者八九个月才把它写完
但是这个说时间上的成本就不提了
另一方面就是说
因为这个第一本的Web Summit书
其实它的内容组织是很难的
就是你要知道说我的Web Summit书
他的群众定位是谁
因为如果你这个东西写不好
你就发现他可能是一个前端的同学看不懂
后端同学就得太简单的因素
所以说我当时写这东西也是很难去找一个定位的
因为你没有人可以参考
我完全是说根据我知道什么东西
然后我来写这个东西
因为我只能参考说我自己知道那些东西
然后官方或者是Russells Community社区有什么东西
然后我从里面抓一些我觉得重要的东西来写
其实说白了
整个定位还是从我自身的考量来出发的
就你没有能不能参考
也没有人能够帮你去参考这个东西
所以这个东西就是
我觉得是写的过程中最难的一个东西
然后写的过程中还有一个难的就是说
这个打移是比较难
因为你知道这个东西
首先它是在国外去发展的印象技术
那其实能找到的
因为当时蜂蜜初期这个东西还没有完全的面向开发者
它其实还算是一个 你可以理解为是个试验品
或者说一个是在试验这个路上的一个东西
所以它的那个文档完全不是面向开发者的
它其实是面向说你想要去转Y怎么开发
比如说你想去设计一个标准
你可以去看我们提供那个文档
因为那个文档都是很灰色难动的
就是如果你没有wizom相关的一些
比如说他这个设计方案
他这些设计方式
他一些细节上的一些考量
如果你都没有sense的话
你是你看定文档是完全看不懂的
那这个时候你就要需要说ok
那我需要我先理解这个内容
然后把它通过这种文字的方式
转换成我的书的内容 对吧
所以我们当时其实打移是蛮难的
那我一般会通过这个side-overflow这种方式
可能会提个问题嘛
或者说在那个github上
这个web相位它有官方的这样一个github
在里面通过这个提Eso的方式
我可能会把我的问题抛出来
然后等大学回答
然后后边直到这个
我认识了那个
这个那个叫什么来着
那个那个那个那个那个
编辑就是我刚才介绍那个编辑的那个那个链路的作者
就是跟他熟悉之后
其实我后边就可能这些邮件来问他
我以为一般会把比如说几个问题
比如说我最近半个月或一个月的问题
然后整理了一个邮件
然后发给他
然后他那边可能一次性回答给我
然后我通组发出来交流的
后边就是
所以这个也是一个比较麻烦的过程
因为写书你要确保内容是正确的
其实我在这个保证内容正确上
这个这个问题上其实花了很多时间
我拿到我拿到一个答案之后
我可能觉得不够
我可能还去比如说通过实验的方式
或者通过这个直接读spec的方式
来去反向验证说
ok 我写的这个这段逻辑
比如说这段内容它是正确的
所以这个我觉得是第二个比较难的地方
但总体我觉得这个结果是好的
这位最后也是整个书也是写出来的
我觉得内容上至少我自己是满意的
至少对于就是对于第一版
web3.0这样一本书来说
我觉得是OK的
嗯对可以可以
我觉得其实这本书的话
本身对于
呃web3.0你这个技术
在国内的一个普及
应该也是有一个很重要的
一个价值的
对可以
我觉得其实还有一些点的话
就是比如说对于
因为刚才游航老师
分享那些经验的话
对于嗯
比如说直播间想写出的同学
其实也有一些参考价值
比如说你想写书的话可以先尝试着先写一些博客
那如果你的内容是比较高质量的
那可能就会有出版社来联系你
看你是不是需要处一处啊之类的
对对对是对是对是的
行那这个过程中啊刚才可能我觉得
于昊师讲的就是也才写书嘛
然后又做了很多分享
其实这一块我觉得也是
呃直播镜头的同学感兴趣的
因为有的同学可能他有有一些技术实力
但是他不知道怎么样去好更好地把这些东西写出来
或者说去分享出来
这个我觉得余航老师可以从你自己的角度能做一些分享
对 其实提高自己的写作和分享技巧
这个就其实我们还是一种
哪怕说笨方法的话也很简单的
那你最简单是说你去参考别人怎么写
然后你自己来练习
所以其实这个就是一套主观权打下来
就是你自己写博客,再加上多看书
那首先读书的话你可以先去看
比如说别人写的这个书
或者你看别人的博客
他的内容是怎么组织的
然后你可以
比如说同类似的方式
比如说我自己研究的一个新技术
然后我也把它写成博客
来记住
然后这个时候你可以看看
我写的博客是不是也能够
按照不同的章节
不同的层次把它分
把它整个内容分开
然后每一个Section
每一块都能够按照顺序来写
所以这个东西就是一个多写多练的一个过程
就像我写书也是一样的
其实我刚开始写可能第一张的时候
它整个的包括你读起来的通风顺
然后你内容组织
其实和后边四五张六七张相比也是不一样的
你会发现其实越写
包括你越来越自己重不去读些内容
你会发现你后边的这样的整个的内容组织
包括语句实际上是更通顺的
实际上是更好的
所以写多几小这个东西就很简单
就是你一定要去多练多去读多去看书
然后才能够把它给练好
你当然就像我说的你写博客不一定要写很多
那比如说我今天学到一个指示点
那你能不能把一个指示点给描述清楚
因为一个指示点其实也可以很好去描述
你可以先比如你先记住说 ok 我这个知识点是什么内容
然后回到这个知识点我来稍微展开一下
比如说跟这个知识点相关的一些其他方面内容
然后最后我可以收个委 比如说通过这个知识点
我能够对我的项目或者说我通过这个知识点
我还能够引述出哪些问题
就说完了你需要去不断的通过你自己写的补课
来锻炼你的思路
然后你的思路不断的被
所以要来到去如果你把整个的线移清楚之后
你就能够知道说
ok 我哪怕从一个很高的层次 overall 的一个角度
或者从细节角度
你都能够看清楚说
我这个博客或者说我这个内容组是不是有问题的
所以还是那句话就是多写博客和多看书
我觉得就是练习这个写作技巧的一个方式
然后分享的话
如果是那种这个比如说
线下或者线上这种这种分享的话
那我建议其实也是一样
就是俩叫多练
就是你可以先从小型的沙龙
因为我们有很多这种小型沙龙
它可能就是讲的比较 specific
比较比较小
比如说我一个知识点
我干的一个知识点
那我都很适合拿在小型沙龙
去分享的
其实你给小型的分享
小型沙龙来去逐渐
练自己的一个一个分享技巧
因为小型沙龙是人少
我觉得最开始人少的话
你也可以很好的这个
克服自己的情绪
包括很好的组织
是自己的这个内容
所以小林沙龙是一个很好的一个实验厂
然后慢慢的之后
你也可以说我逐渐去脱离主字稿
因为很多人可能说
我为了保证说我的分享是ok的
我可能我先写了几千字主字稿
我觉得这个是ok的
这个是很好的一个方式
但是随着你这个慢慢去
对你的内容为了属性
然后你的情绪条件为了要好
其实你逐渐可以把主字稿
变成一个keypoint
就是你把你的关键的点列一下
比如说我这一个slide
那我可能要讲五个点
我把五个点列起来就ok了
然后慢慢你就不需要主字稿
你就直接按照你的思路
来对几批评下来讲就ok了
因为我觉得就是对着主字稿讲
本身也是一个这种就是
其实有说你讲一讲你发现
你的思路可能也跟不上了
所以我建议是说你编曲思考编曲讲
这是一个比较好的一个方式
但整体还是说建议从小银沙楼开始
但是慢慢的我这个逐渐这个人越来越多
然后我这个这个逐渐也是处理组织稿
然后越来越成熟
所以这个是练习分享的一个
也不算技巧吧
我觉得就是一个方式吧
因为我是觉得没有说能够离开剑影的一个技巧
说让你立马就能从一个这种特别紧张
然后也不会组织内容的一个小白
突然变成一个这种分享高手
我觉得这个都不会的
非常肯定要是慢慢练的
对
明白
OK 我觉得
确实那个
余淮老师讲得很详细啊
就是直播间如果真的有这样的诉求
同学可以做一下参考
确实这个东西
它其实是一些技巧相关的东西嘛
它其实是需要练习的
它
这个东西你可能
对 就是的
花时间去训练
其实最终都会变得
变好
OK
然后
对 还有一个
对
对 其实还有一个我想说就是说
就是你练习分享的话
还有一个就是比如你平时开会
其实分享不一定要说我
有一个topic
然后答正是做那里讲
比如说你开会
那你能不能
很好地把自己的想法给表达清楚
给你的team member去讲一讲
我觉得这也是一个练习的方式对吧
你现在从日常的工作中
能够把它练好的话
那其实你的分享能力不会差的
明白
这其实也是一个不错的技巧
ok 那我们
前面讲都是比较干岸东西嘛
我们可能得讲一讲像比较轻松的
因为我们知道就是
余浩老师也是我们前端圈里面
应该比较知名的女装大佬了
对 我其实想聊一下
就比如说我们看这些女装大佬
好像普遍技术都挺好的
所以想聊一下中间有没有一些
对对对 就是有一些关联性
这个我还真不知道,反正这个东西我觉得可能是一个巧合吧,就是
我觉得可能是个巧合,因为我在我看来可能没有什么太多的这个理论上的支撑吧,可能就是
只是说错巧可能你认识的几个朋友他可能都是有这方面的一些小爱好,然后这个技术本身还不错的可能
其实这个东西就怎么讲
就是你可以把它理解为跟打游戏是一样的
就是有的人可能喜欢平时玩游戏
或者有的人喜欢看剧
其实也是一样的
只不过这个还好可能比较 special 语念
就是人可能比较少
但我觉得你把它当作一个跟打游戏
然后看剧啊
就是耍剧或者其他的一些方式
一样的一类的这样一个东西
其实我觉得就比较正常了
有些人可能他可愛看動漫,但是技術能力也很強,其實這幾個人也蠻多的,我也是蠻多的,大家可能說他在南,但是技術真的是很牛,很牛很厲害,所以這個也是一個很正常的,畢竟大家學技術學多了,可能都要找些事先來放鬆一下。
对吧,明白
对,其实我觉得我们想问这个问题其实也是想要聊一些关于可能对程序员偏见的一个东西
对,就大家可能普遍对程序员的认知就是非常默论啊,然后无趣,可能也不上一说话,每天可能就只是会对着电脑
然后,对,然后可能,可能头发也很少
对,这个好像就是大家有一些比较刻板的认知吧
但是其实在我认识的朋友里面确实有很多特别有意思
比如说我们看那个庞博嘛
他也是程序员,但是他在脱博学大会其实就很精彩
然后我们再看看一些
反正我生活中我认识的还有一个就是以前阿里的一个批巴
就是Shanley Ray吧
就是陕总
他其实也是很喜欢女状的嘛
还有很多朋友可能弹钢琴他的很厉害,或者吉他很厉害,包括我们之前有一位讲师就是戴敏老师,他其实是移动段码,然后iOS圈里面画画画得很好,所以我觉得这个圈子也没有那么多刻板的印象,大家其实更多的。
一东你这个就就是一个啊你这夸哈夸哈那么厉害
我其实也是就是一点爱好吧你就是代表吗
没有没有你就是明显是代表
对所以我觉得可能就是能就是能
大概的把大家的一些刻板印象去做一些
呃 莫楚吧 我是觉得呃 如果后面我们这个节目啊如果真的火了我觉得这可能也是一个很好的topic
让大家去消除一些的程序员的偏见 因为我觉得这个群体首先呃 它肯定是个很高智商的一个群体
因为真的要去很至少说逻辑性应该是很强的 还要去把一些逻辑东西弄清楚
这个是不容易的 所以很多时候他说他目的或者呆板可能是因为他在工作的时候其实比较专注
会让你觉得他有这样的一些情况
但是其实我觉得在私下里面
大家都是很有趣的人
是
那我们接下来回到一些偏公司方面的一些东西吧
因为其实
我们知道宇航现在也在paper嘛
其实应该是一家很纯的外企了
所以想了解一下
就像这种外企的话
它的工程师文化是什么样子的
跟这种因为你也在国内的公司带过嘛
区别可以大概讲一下
嗯 对 其实还是有区别的 呃 首先就是这个
work-life balance 这个大家都知道 外企这个生活和工作需要一个平衡的
那不像国内的公司 可能这个996啊 或者加班什么的会比较多
然后外企可能其他的就是一个比较特性就是
但我可能说难听点就是可能没有这种poa什么这种
这种现象,至少我周围是没有的
我觉得大家可能还是去说
就是讨论事比较多一些
然后呢
至少我的team我的这个老板
整个对整个team来说都是
特别用心的,也是说
就是
花了很多时间去做这些事情
并不说只是说为了这个技校KPI去做那些事情
就说白了
大家还是一个team,然后一起有一个这样一个目标去做事情
而不是说每一个人都有自己的利益在那里
然后做自己的利益搜索
那可能就POA别人或者这么怎么样
我觉得这些乱七八糟的事情
其实在这边是
首先第一点是没有
然后第二点是说公司也延连禁止的
那我每年其实都会有这个training去强调说
比如说公司内部有哪些行为是不能有的
比如说刚才讲的这种POA行为是肯定不能存在的
那如果有的话
你可以勇敢地去相关的一些
我们有很多种部门你可以做举报的
举报之后其实这个还是蛮严格的
作为外企的话
因为像佩佩奥其实他是一个国际公司
就是他globalize的话
他的很多的这些规定都是统一的
比如我刚才讲的这些内容
你不能poA
你不能有一些心事而绕的行为
或者是一些想法都不行的
所以说我觉得
我觉得这可能就是一个外企的好处,就你发现各国家的人都在这边,那你同事也是各国家的人,其实你本身做事情就相对会小心一些,那比如说我们,因为你说就是说你不同的文化可能会有这conflict,那你不能说我还拿着国内那一套这个方式来这边来工作。
那这样的话其实你本身首先这个就可能会产生其中不尊重人家文化的行为嘛。
那第二点就是说本身对你整个的这个公司的这个调例
或者说一些管理规范来说也是一个就是不允许的一个东西
所以这就是外企的一个点
人多文化也多
那你需要很谨慎的去cover你那部分行为你的behavior人的文化
然后去按照公司的规律上去做事情
然后文化也多的话就是这个怎么讲也是蛮有趣的
反正就是就是你会发现
因为我们team其实是蛮多的嘛
就是有这个印度同学
有这个美国的同学
然后还有韩国的同学
就是我们开会的话呢就是
就是刚开始的话可能会闲聊的话
你会发现各国家的人
各国家他们做的事情
可能也都比较有意思
我们可能会闲聊闲聊
然后你会遇到各种各样的这个
就你会发现其实不同的这个team
或者不同的人
他们做事的思路和方法也不太一样
其实你需要去这个也不能说客服
你需要去适应很多很多种diversity
这个是很重要的一个点
就是在国内你会发现
我美公司可能都是类似的
说你从哪里出来
那你去内亚的公司腾讯你
其实八九不历史的对吧
你的整个流程啊
包括一些这个比黑鱼
包括其他的一种东西都是类似的
但是你在这种国家化公司
你反映就不一样
就整个的东西你自己要去试一个的
这diversity其实也是比较好的一个东西
就是可能也看人
因為有的人可能不太適應
有的人覺得
就按不住搬動事情跟他表現的
就有些人可能覺得
有diversity
那我整個公司文化
整個這種分別可能更輕鬆一些
所以可能也有人要看
然後說出我們公司的這個工程師文化的話
整體而言其實
我覺得可能也不是很
不是特別濃嘛
就是PayPal 表示它是一個
這我怎麼講
就是或說國外的企業都有這樣一個特點
就是说我的这个公司
比如说我们是做支付的是吧
那其实我们可能除了支付
这块主要业务之外的一些东西
可能我们自己不会去做
那比如说我们有很多这种OA系统
比如说有这种
比如其他的一些这种
考有的比如说考成请假系统
其实也是OA的一部分嘛
那这个东西可能我们内部就不会说
像阿里一样说
我们这些招聘的系统
也需要招通这些来写
那我们就比如说像文档那我们就google doc就完事了
就会用microsoft的doc
我们也不会说自己成立一个team去洗
那我们可能更多的人还是去做跟我们主营业务相关的事情
那比如说我一边是compliance team
那我们去做跟合规相关的东西
我们会做一些用程序一些service来去
辅助去完善我的compliance相关的一些流程
而不会花很多时间去做其他的东西
我觉得这个是跟国内公司可能不太一样的地方
对,就是我们做的东西肯定是跟我们的主业有相关的
其他的只要是你能够比如说通过替我们搬点产品
或者说花钱请外包团来写的能解决的问题
我们都不会说让权权够来做
就像我们的这个表弹工具
我们用slap和teams
但我们不会说自己去开发一套这个东西
但你像其他阿里可能就
这个什么东西都自己来写
我觉得这个区别就
蛮大的
然后PayPal其实
就像我说它其实是一个技术产品
这个发展的RI导向的
就是不会说去
做大而全
那我们可能都是用的是Mundler的产品
比如说这个Substance
还有一些其他的一些公司的一些产品
来去
为我们的主营业务提供服务
嗯,对,这个是这个是跟这个国内公司不太一样的地方
然后除此之外这个work balance啊,然后什么股票啊这种
其实都是类似的,我们就是全持股嘛
然后其他的就是这个,还有一些保险啊
还有一些这个其他的一些啊,这个这个这个这个
啊,我们讲就是一些其他的一些公司给到处理
也都是有的,对,也都是有的
然后技术这边的话
如果就前段而言
其实PL这边因为是T39的Member
对 如果说在我们这边的话
这个你可以去T39 committee
就参加那个
应该是Quartley的一个会
然后去看整个前端
或者Jobscom这块发展的情况
然后其他的其实像
这个Node的体系
我们也是在不断完善的
我觉得
虽然说我觉得整个成熟度
可能没有阿里做那么深
就是那么那么那么deep dive
但我觉得整个的这个公司文化还是蛮清晰的
就是比较轻松
然后呢也不是说就不做事情
但大家可能还是有一个共同的目标的
比如说我这个infra
我的这个基建在什么情况下
做什么样的事情
做一个什么样的程度
大家也都是有目标的
对
但总体而言还是说
就所有这些做做的事情
包括infra还都是为了
都是为了我们公司的这个主营业务服务的
就是如果说他不是为了
我们主要有服务的,那其实我们就不会去自己做
你可以理解,就是我们可能会花钱请外包
或者是直接购买Wander的产品
里面有很多SARS服务嘛
我们直接请外就用就OK了
所以这是配票的一个一个工程室文化的这样一个体现吧
我觉得
嗯
这感觉下来确实跟内地的一些工资期差别还蛮大
确实差别挺大
对
对,是的
像我其实刚刚到这边的话
我其实我 我就让POP就适应时间的话
我觉得我适应六半年时间吧
我觉得
因为我刚开始去那边其实很小心翼翼的
我觉得 你看我给一个Dracar发邮件
比如说我有某个会可能没参加
或者这个错过了
我当时还想说
哎呦 我再帮我说一声
我这个
因为有些事情可能没来得及
就就过掉了
但是后来人家说没关系的
这个其实无所谓的
就大家其实都知道
就是每个人其实做事情都是靠自己的
都是靠自己的一个自屈力的
而不是说我一定要你过来做什么事情
但如果说比如说某个会
那你没有障碍的话
那其实我们就默认会觉得说
你可能是有什么急事情
那没有障碍
其实没有什么关系的
但我觉得其实听下来之后
其实可能还是看个人选择
我觉得有的同学
就是我们直播间有的
所以不一定是这样的氛围
那其实是取决于你自己
可能想要一个什么样的环境
因为我对解内地的话可能就是如果是你在这个比如说大的公司
你在这个核心团队里面如果你进入这个核心团队
可能你能接入到的东西会更深或者说在短时间内能得到的一些成长可能会更多
这个我只是觉得有可能啊
比如说你如果在一个核心的那块技术的团队里面
所以我觉得这个可能确实因人而異
对是的这个哎呀反正就是大家可以先了解吗
我觉得就是不要急着说
比如说听谁这个东西到哪个公司就特别好
你就急着去去做什么事
我就大概多了解了解
然后多看看这些人到底过得真实情况是怎么样
如果你看到的时候他好就真的好
其实所以很多人说想去想认谋
我觉得这个东西在我来看来
我觉得还是不要听风就是雨
就你自己一定要知道
OK我在一个外企什么情况
那我去外国的工作了生活了
那我的这个生活会什么样变化
我的文化上會不會有什麼衝突
會不會有什麼不適用的地方
盡自己要去先知道的
就不能說別人走了
你也跟著你馬前面
後腿就過去
對
這也是其實我們做這個
這個系列活動的一個目的
因為我們在這個EVE訪談的環境
我們其實會有很多類似這樣的問題
問到不同的公司
然後不同的背景的這些講師
然後看看他現在的一個狀況
我們其實
大家如果我們其實
希望我們後面這個
大廠作業發系列活動
可以作为一个类似
可以参考的一个点
比如说你对某一种类型的公司感兴趣
你就可以去看看那一期的节目
看看我们在那里面那个专家
他是怎么去评价当前这个
公司的一些状况
对
不得不同的消息
好的
那我们就讲另外一个点
就是如果可能有一些同学
有一些选择了
比如说他可能就
想看看paypal的机会
但其实比如说像paypal
他可能会看中
这个候选人什么样的品质呢
对 这个其实
我觉得整体来看的话
大部分的這個要求其實是跟其他的公司也是類似的
首先我們就是可能對照著你要去硬幣的那個position
那個崗位那你首先技術能力肯定要說ok的
但是包括PayPal在內的國外的公司可能一般
至少我這邊也是一樣的
我可能不會考太多八股文
基本上也不會考八股文
比如說看圓碼就一定要低不大什麼程度
我們一般也是會根據這個簡歷上的
你简历上写的这些问题来问你一些相关的一些问题
然后同时也会根据我们这边的需求来去问你相关的问题
而不是说问你随便找一些这些八股文的问题来问
然后终于来看的话
外形其实相对测重的可能是你这个我们说基础 技术储备
就是算法这块的能力
那前段这块可能会稍微没有那么看重
但整体上我们也会考
就是你一些基本的算法
你可能要ok 要扎实
然后呢
除此之外的就是沟通
就是
嗯你我们需要确保说
你这个沟通能力是ok的
那我们一般会说
在面试过程中来看
比如说
我们在问一些问题的时候
候选人他的回答是怎么样的
他也没有完全
get到我的point
来投入方向来评估说我的过程
他的功能力怎么样
能不能够
在后续的这个工作过程中
能够完全去理解
比如说你的leadership
或者你的team member的人
他们又是什么样的反馈
所以这个是很壮的一点
然后再就是一个语言层面
语言层面这个东西
其实也有很多人问
说外星人是英语或是对英语有什么需求
这个的话整体起来看还是看你的应聘直辑的
但是总体来说
哪怕是比较低的来往
你的基本的读和写是必须要有的
然后听力和口语的话
至少能做到
比如说我简单的回答性问题
这个是要需要有的
因为除非说你是完全背似在国内的整个team
像我们其实做的是global的一些产品
那其实你就没有办法说你的team肯定是外国人的
那你哪怕说你这个不用天天开会
但如果有些紧急的问题
你需要这个就是跟他靠一下的话
那其实你也能要能大声的听懂
毕竟能够做出反馈说
OK我怎么处理这些事情
给到一个色录审议决策
但如果说你的Level 9高项
比如做到Manager或者Silly Manager或更高的Level
其实这个过程就比较重要了
因为有的时候你可能需要
比如说你的team就一两百人了
那你可能作为一个Leadership
你需要去发言的
对吧
这个东西就不只是语言能为了
就是你要怎么讲
讲话的艺术就在这里面
所以你做Leadership
什么该讲 什么不该讲
该怎么去讲一个事情
把一个坏事讲上一个
让人能接受的一个坏的事情
这些都是可能就是软禁的那个层面
你需要去不断的去提升了
对 但是总的来看我们都是会根据你去招聘的
JD上的要求来去对你进行考察
对 除此之外的内容不会说乱问一些问题
然后去搞一些没用的东西
对 明白
所以这个其实我不要有感触
因为我其实相当也是从一个国内的环境切换到了
这个global的一个环境嘛
然后因为我也是manager 觉得其实在很多时候要要要去说话
然后做一些这种公开的讲话或者说是
可能做一些
像下面t2的辅导所以我觉得在这个英语的过程中
其实对我来说挑战蛮大的
因为我会发现比如说我用中文讲可能
会讲的比较好但是如果想把这个东西转换成英文的可能他会打个类似
七折八折的样子这个其实是语言上面
比较难的
因为可能你正常的时候,你能知道用一些词去表达,就是很直白的去表达那个中文的意思,但是可能在英文里面会有一些不同的,呃,这种语言的技巧,对,他可能是你比较难去学到的,需要比较长的时间。
确实。
对,是。
OK,所以我觉得可能对于我们直播签,对这个方向感性和这种,我觉得这个语言可能会是一个比较,也会成为一个比较大的挑战,可能。
除了技术吧。
对 是语 对的是的
对这个的话就是看
就是如果大家有兴趣
比如说到外企或者说到外海工作的话
其实可以
因为英语跟英文说出来也没有接近的
就是就跟你演讲一样
我不可能说第一天是个什么都不会的
第二天我就透复能考虑一把二
这个我觉得不现实的
像单词或者一些口语听力
就是需要你每天去看的
但如果说你很早决定的时候
我要去到外企工作的话
那我建议你就提前准备起来
比如说提前了半年
然后每天花点时间
一个小时啊
半个小时啊
去比比兰斯啊
或者做厅厅啊
我觉得这个是要
要日记越来越去积累的
这个真的没有办法
就是如果你没有那个语境的话
本身你学英语就是比较慢的
但如果说你
你再不去自己去
铺持自己去做这个事情的话
那基本上就
很难有提高
就是实话
对的
行啊
那我们今天就
我们今天最后一个问题吧
就是我觉得
对广大的前端开发者来说
我觉得从你的角度
你觉得后续大概拿去发展会比较好一点
对 实际上对我想讲的可能
就不只是做前端
因为就是其实对所有开玩笑
可能都比较适应的地方
就是说你一定要去学会这个终身学习
然后去抓住那些不一遍的东西学
那我举个例子
比如说这个A这个人
他可能会经常去学一些比如说
框架的一些东西
比如说我一个框架它在某一个版本下它是怎么实现的
它会一直追着这个框架去不断去看圆码
但B它可能会学比如说框架整个的这个基本结构设计是什么样子
然后学一些框架内部的一些比如说这个一些编码的一些原则
比如说一些范围史
而不是说我带不到具体的这个东西
比如说哪个代码在哪里写的
它用了什么语法
然后怎么去实现这个东西的
就是你一定要去抓住这些不一样的去学
比如说算法加购设计 比如说提起结构 比如说一些编码的范图
这个东西其实它可以套用在你任何一种语言上 任何一个加购实现上 任何一个软件实现上
因为你如果去抓着这个原代码实现 比如说我现在是A实现
那我这个框架开发者我发现过了一年我用了B实现 B实现比A实现要更好一些
那其实你根本抓住它内部的比如说一些比较精准的东西
你一直跟着这个框架的变化去走
你会发现你自己只能够够夸在这一个框架里面
比如说那我闭框架说我想用A框架的一个价格设计
那我让你来给P框架提供一些建议
那这个时候你发现B框架跟A框架实相完全不一样
对吧 那我没法去套用
但是我又没有去学习那些不一遍的东西
比如说价格设计 比如说一些范氏一些东西
那你就发现我这个东西没法去做一个很简单的套用
一个转移
所以我就是一定要去学那些首先
优先去学那些不一遍的东西
就是像我说的算法 价格设计这类东西
然后其次比如说你这个
比如说你工作中用到了
比如说我需要看Deep Dev到原码这个level了
就一件事跟你工作相关的
或者说你感兴趣 你真的要感兴趣
那我就都OK的 这个都OK的
然后你再去提不带不到具体的软件原码
编程语言 框架的使用方式
这些一遍的部分再去看
就一定要是说先学那些不便的东西
然后再去根据你的需求
再去抓那些一遍的东西
这个东西就是这样的
就是你的RI来看的话
你不便的东西RI会高一显
一遍的东西它只是说
除非为了你为了去解决你的工作者的问题
或者说你自身的感兴趣
或者说你自己开了项目的一些问题
那你再去看就OK了
然后除此之外还有就是要警惕这个架构师这个称号
因为很多人就就说
问你说我架构师比如给我前端架构师或者说后端架构师
我架构师跟普通的开发者是不是有区别
架构师是不是一定
就是要做这种很大的冲突系统
然后去一个人去掌握几百个服务几千个服务去做这种architecture
但实际上并不是的
你会发现
但架构这个诗它可以用在这种大量的架构系统上
但是它也可以套用在你的一个原代码的实现上
你会发现其实有些自称架构诗的人
他让他写一个简单的功能
可能几百行代码你会发现它根本就写不好
它可能没法把这个比如抽象分层用得很好
那其实我觉得这种所谓的这种对基本的这种coding你问的都写不好的话
那其实你很难承担这个架构诗这个程度
所以大家不要去说我做架构师已经一定要脱离扣领
然后去做一个很大的架构设计
或做很大的一个service 层面的架构
那实际上架构师的训练是从你开始写代码就开始了的
如果说你能把一个代码比如说一个面条代码
然后通过你的经验
把它通过分层抽象
整个内部的各component之间的关系给处理好
并且让它保持一定的可谓互信和扩展性
那么我觉得你就是一个很好的架构史
就是大家不用去执着一个架构史称号
一定要去架构什么service
一定要是从你写的代码当时的项目去出发
然后尝试把代码层面的东西架构好
然后你才能够把微观层面的代码架构
然后逐渐把它放大到整个service层面去做
去做一个更好的一个调度
所以这个是另外一个就是一个陷阱
就不要去过于纠结架构是一个称号
然后再就是说我这个有你行业发展其实很难预测呢
比如说我说前端在未来五年十年哪些能够
挫远而出哪些技术是哪些哪些技术是能够挫远而出哪些地方能成为这个
一个一个一个一个一个蓝海
那其实我觉得没有人能预测出来
五年前大家觉得他可能两三年就能够成为一个点了
一个break in point
但是实际上到现在你会发现其实很多提案还是在不断的去实现中
现在我也很难说两年之后他是不是还能够保持竞争力
但唯独你需要做的是说在这样一个比较乱的环境中
你自己其实要有一个竞争力
所以我说的是你一定要去抓那些不一遍的东西去学
然后逐渐积累自己这种比较基础的稳固知识的这样一个实力
保证你自己的精神、精神力
然后在这个基础之上你可能要抓住机会
因为就像比如说有某些情况
比如说你我举个例子啊
比如说P8这个智级
还有说到P9
其实你光靠精神力可能也不够
在某些体系下
比如说我这个整个的从上到下
Leadership到你这一层
你发现中间就没有一个空的位置能够给你什么啤酒去呆了
那其实你就发现这东西没法省
就是哪怕你已经很牛了
但是从组织价格层面
你的这个竞争就是没法实现的
这种就是很常有的很常见的事情
所以大家销售就是说
你在保证自身竞争力的同时
然后去看几云看几亩
但如果你有这样一个机会了
比如说现在有空位了
有人走了
对吧
你上面没有人去立等
那你现在也能做精神了
那你看看你能不能去抓到这个机会
去做这样一个评论
如果你做不好
那你就保持自己的竞争力
然后随时准备好
就是迎接这样一个机会
因为这个很现实
不是说你怎么样怎么样
你达到一个固定的要求
你就能够就是自动去往上
评论到另一个level
明白
就越往上学 越是这样的
这个这个就是没有办法
因为比如说你像P5P6
其实它很简单
我可能就用一些
条件包括那些
比如說OK 我達到什麼程度 你就能夠競爭
但你說你P9P10 你跟我說你區分一個
他們兩個之間的不同的一個scale size
或者說一個影響力 那我覺得很難去區分 對吧
無非就是說 在適當的時候 你本身也足夠了
你強大 然後有這個機會 一個空位給你了
然後你可能你順著推走 你就上去了
一般都是這種情況 很少有這種
真的是硬行要求说一个teleport换你满足就进行了
所以没有办法
这就很现实的问题
大家能做的是说
保持你自己的竞争力
然后不断学习
然后不断的去培养你的硬技能也好
软技能也好
然后
在特征的时候
如果有机会你抓住就ok了
对好的
我这边就是对
好的好的
非常感谢
丁昊老师